was mich also kritisch das ist ja alle
trend geht zum sogenannten major und die
idee dass du quasi wenn du geboren
herrschaft frauen ziemlich bald noch er
ist erotik macht buch strafkick vagina
strafparagrafen die vorher
und wer so denkt hat sich doch glaubhaft
eine frau darf man nicht auf sie dass
sie schwanger ist oder was ja aber du
bist und du findest irgendwie
nachvollziehbar wenn sie finden seit er
das alter nicht so auf sich hat im tor
feiert das ich vielleicht zu straffen
und so das ist doch der anfang verteilen
[Musik]
heute aber das ist fleisch und bossard
mit dem ihf und barbara diskutiere
philosophische auftragslage heute zur
frage was ist schönheit das macht mich
schön bin ich schön
ich wende mich endlich andere keine wird
merken wirtschaftlich machen das ganz
auf fleisch wird es eben auch immer man
nicht du ich da nichts aber es gab schon
gern anders spürbaren viel größer aber
wahrscheinlich noch glaube ich ist ein
anderer
das sieht ganz oft macht ihm asiatische
rennstrecke
aber ich habe schon oft bleibt werde ich
alles natürlich also wenn sie sagen dass
fast zum beispiel sagt der viele leute
noch ein wahrscheinlich nicht so
sympathisch wolken und mit der zeit wäre
unser bad oder dann werde ich eben oder
aber das wo du schon andere aber ich
finde dich gibt es aber schon ganz
richtig unterscheiden es geht
schönheits-op so gemacht werden wenn wir
wieder so weit musste vorher also der
natürliche alterungsprozess waren für
andere tut nicht so gut gefällt und dann
dieser fehler machen oder sich gar farbe
oder kapitän wieder lobbys machen und
schönheits op s handelt das man auch
also aus kenia hat also irgendwie ideal
klären
das glaube ich sind zwei ganz andere
kategorie weil ich ein schlechter ich
weiß gar nicht erst mal wird werde aber
ich hoffe das erste klappe nie
verstanden ist natürlich habe darüber
diskutieren wieso ich eigentlich alt war
sichtbar altes problem gehört das schon
immer so dass man studiert hat
jugendliche ist gesät jugendlichkeit
kultivieren und so aber trotzdem noch
ganz viel darüber sagen aber ich finde
es normal bis anders euro man quasi seit
ich werde vor dem edel marken mit tempo
und sagt diana sie biete das system
fließen die unterscheidung und das
andere ist also etwas weiter von der
vergänglichkeit und ich finde das ist
schön
jugendlich sage ich jetzt ja gut das ist
zwar unterschiedlich behandelt glatze
nicht um den land rover pflanzen
ja ja ich sage nicht dass ausgesagt
im moment ist für mich okay ich habe
aber vorstellen oder sich eine situation
kommen wo nicht finden ich stoffen spiel
gesehen nur noch immer irgendwie da
hängen die holz oder regen wir die
falten oder so und reduzieren mit
sauldorf 1000 mich selbst für kenner und
da finde ich klasse geht also gerade
kürzlich einen dokfilm gehen vom
schweizer fernsehen über
schönheitsoperationen und ist um den
total haus gegangen bin ich erschrocken
über gestapelte gemerkt habe genau ich
habe das noch nie gehört vorher in dutum
haus ist eine mit so hat es auch schon
ab und auf was auch junge leute mit die
sorge um das wort denn die frau die den
film operiere das quartett und das doch
oft so dass plötzlich ein begriff
begeistert und den dank produkt nur in
spiegel und dazu habe ich das auch wills
das wort geht und ganz viel
schönheitsideal werden plötzlich etwas
nicht einfach dazugehört ich glaube zum
schönheitsideal kürze zu dass zumindest
eine künstliche dass es nicht optimiert
ausgesehen aber hat ihr könnt mir einige
sind aber ich bin so mit zahlen oder das
sind die kraft bringt lieder vielleicht
das ist irgendwie dass das gehört dazu
also sache und das macht sie irgendwie
aber gegen charakter aber eigentlich
also der schönheitsbegriff vorschlag ist
doch lieber und platten oder geplanter
nur die fähigkeit es gibt objektive idee
für schönheit und ihr thema damit tue
das schöne eigentliche idee vom schöne
entspricht und dass ich bin noch derart
idee von der vernunft das heißt die dvd
von und spielgeräte schöne gegenstandes
stück wird genau also ich würde sagen
den blöcken gibt es das eine dass die
verbindung zwischen schöne und gute di
carlo kkt auf griechisch und sondern ist
aber nicht würdig dagegen argumentieren
der objektiven muss also ich finde
schönheit ist sicher nicht das objektiv
sowie die platten das verstanden es gibt
viele unterschiedliche gesichter
es geht twitter konsens darüber ungefähr
was ein schönes gesicht was man auch das
jugendlichkeit das ist reine hut das ist
geschlechtlichkeit also dass eine frau
findet tendenziell eher schöner wenn sie
liebliche steht also immer größere
lebten und so und mit dem anregen die
wangenknochen als praktisch männlichkeit
oder andere mini tätig draußen so frisch
das sind immer noch mal statistik dass
das irgendwie kulturell bedingt ist aber
das geht wirklich so eine gemeinsame
grund sein oder asymmetrie ist
eigentlich der schönheitsbegriff manuel
kann für die kritik der urteilskraft
derzeit schön ist was ohne begriff
allgemein gefällt mit dem material ohne
begriff also nicht so wie eine
mathematische formeln machen sozusagen
objektiv ausrechnen was schön ist aber
doch allgemein es geht so avisiert
kultur übergriffen die allgemeine
schönheits grundsätzen gold gewinnt
harmonie lehre der musik zum beispiel ja
ich finde das ist also schönheit da ich
wäre wohl proportionierten teil der
harmonie
aber es gibt ein rockkonzert nur
irgendwie kann es tische weiter es geht
irgendwie ein ruine wo in romantisches
in cannes ästhetische weiter wo man als
schön empfinden aber das sind halt ein
anderes lager sind ja wo tetris spielen
aber selbst die maßnahme zu es gibt
keine absolut gibt das man eigentlich
denke ich dass response fehlen und
gleichzeitig frage wie ist es wenn es um
schönheit gott klassische schönheit für
menschen direkt sagt annika des
durchschnitts so schön schön und
gleichzeitig spezialist und philosoph
und wenig zeit zum beispiel der fall
wenn das schönheitsideal steht eine
große starke bei der schönheitsideal weg
der heutige zieht durch sein das nimmt
zu es geht also bis wie eine
optimierungs und enorm jährige druck und
als ideal die werbebilder all die
sozialen medien oder geister die die
milliarde vorbildlich
china zählt alles gefehlt hat alles
optimiert ausklingt das ganze durch und
bleibt ist das bild von normalität und
vom idealmaß seiten über die total auf
kreta das jetzt schon immer gehe so
bildet mit dem motto bilder und motive
aber wir kommen immer ganz viel machen
dass begriffe so stark tragen hat damit
zu tun dass man sich immer fragen will
jetzt ein bisschen machen oder sogar
musik machen und das findet tragische
bruder plötzlich wieder körper komplett
normier war optimieren waren noch alles
für andere und das geht ja auch der
effekt von sogenannter lukas uns also
die diskriminierung von lytro
unterdurchschnittlich aus sein oder
schlechter es sein das kann man noch wie
sie die werden wir haben schlechtere
noten sie werden weniger befördert wenig
stellt und dass er hat eher handfest ich
wollen für diskriminierung wenn das im
internet verbindet die gesellschaftliche
dynamik und tierwohl findet echte sorgen
ich bin und wenn die noch erlaubt island
ähnlich verteilen
es wäre jetzt die wohl schön auf die
wand zu sehen das hatte dir das
irgendwie verdient ist ja dafür machte
dieses jahres lobt er ihn unter das ist
ja anschließt wird überall so aus in
brasilien so der brasilien betrifft
nach klasse also sonst wirklich
infiziert wie kim kardashian das darf
man den maxi dass das gemacht ist und
das ist nicht schlecht das finde ich
interessant sind wie kulturell sportlich
also mir ist nichts
du musst immer ausgesehen hat über
schönheit darunter zwölf kinder ist und
ich glaube ich habe mir das auch nie
neutral über das alles gegen dich so
stehen im lenovo ganz kritisch ist und
wo innerhalb der feministischen hecken
unsere einmal zahlen alle aktiven 18 5%
oder schönheits-op es weltweit und ist
schon extrem zunehmende markt auf dem
anderen
die einzelnen schönheits-op jetzt
kritisieren weil sich zeigen ob das
richtig ist aber sie stehen hinten trotz
erkennen und über das zu reden ist
wichtig der andere punkt ist woher die
ideal und schönheit die frauen ganz auf
die pornoindustrie die meisten auch die
schönheits-op es um die wurst und sich
innerlich schamlippen
und ich mich schon irgendwie frage
momentan sind sehr schöne frauen aber
das finde ich wirklich extrem stoßen ja
und dann stand die frage ja aber ich
mache das nicht für mich macht seine
personen verletzungen sind nicht was ist
denn aber ich habe begriffen dass
bestehende crew ihren komplexen ist
immer einmal sagen es geht hoch wie im
entspannte sind bestehen mit thomas mann
verlange dass er fragen so eine op macht
informiert wird und freiwillig das macht
und das ist ganz oft schon lange
schleppe die frauen zur
schönheitsoperation sicherheitsminister
raum leben stören
velofahrer aber eigentlich wird er es
geht darum finde das ist schon mal sehr
stark ist das eine ganz andere ist als
informiert sie viel fremdes land geprüft
machen oder brasilien trifft das ist
tragisch mit frauen bis zum bahnhof aus
israel and also das bestimmt wird durch
lange verletzt und dann geht es
natürlich um eine erweiterte
selbstbestimmung die cops mit
hintergrund bedingungen also bin ich
wirklich noch aus bestimmten wunsch es
für die 2 wenn ich einfach weiß summen
zurück ist wenn ich das vor den wenigen
im innen oder es wird als peter klug die
sozialen medien wenn ich mit soundso
ausgesehen
und dann kommen ja folge ist das
wirklich noch freiheit ja wie ist das
bei euch findet er auch schön und was
haltet ihr von schönheits-ops messer
gespannt auf diskussionen kommen da und
wenn der mehr zum thema wissen
der dokfilm das optimierte gesicht hat
immer nur ärger und halb sternstunde der
nacht über das thema normal
und wenn der vorstand denkt an glocken
aktivieren